[Applause]
you're watching white coming up on this
week's program Chris gets his claws on
the tech controlling the perfect
animatronic star push push push as hard
as keV
push push nice I find out what a
pocket-sized Jim feels like and Luke's
join the battle to take back a dystopia
run by machines in a games review
welcome to swipe we've come to the
wearable technology show in London this
week the organizers here say it's the
biggest event for wearable and net
connected technology in the world we're
gonna talk more about clever things you
can wear a bit later because first we're
gonna check in with Chris who this week
pounced at the chance to hang out with a
leopard
it might look and sound real but there's
nothing natural about this big cats
it's an animatronic leopard a robot
feline dressed in fake fur it's being
used as part of a National Geographic
campaign to raise awareness of the
plight of endangered big cats
it took 15 people five weeks to build
the beast from scratch there's about 30
or 40 different movements in there
including eye mechanisms ears sniff or
growl then we've got the full neck
movement you've got a tail breathing
mechanism so it's all engineered based
on the anatomy of a real leopard can you
show me how to use it how do I make it
growl for example so if you pull the
right stick to the right and the right
switch up after three it will growl so
one two three
scary and then if we go to this
transmitter over here you can see we've
got the tail on there and the breathing
[Laughter]
so how does it go from being a metal
skeleton to the finished article you can
see here that we've we've got the foam
latex skin here on top of the fiberglass
core if for example we want it to sniff
or growl then we need a mechanism that
can manipulate that skin in that in that
way and we would look at that and work
out where we want to have the mechanisms
and move the skin painters then give the
animal its spots
John's studio has built various robots
for TV adverts and films like those in
the Harry Potter franchise but creating
lifelike machines is time-consuming and
labor-intensive so with Hollywood
blockbusters making more and more use of
CGI or animatronics likely to become
redundant one day I think the benefits
of using animatronics is the in-camera
interaction I think that's probably the
the best thing because we you know you
have an actor on set with an animatronic
and they can actually relate to it and
and and act against it and we can
puppeteer and and control it also from a
technical point of view it can be lit
and it actually feels like it's there
with sometimes with CGI and depending on
the budget especially it can feel like
it's a bit too glossy and it doesn't
feel like it's actually there and you
have actors the perhaps acting to tennis
ball on the end of a stick instead of a
dragon for example
for John and his team making lifelike
robots is clearly a passion and with new
techniques like 3d printing helping to
drive down costs in the industry there's
plenty of work opportunities for people
like him to sink their teeth into Chris
Creegan Sky News here are things like
still to come I will be getting a good
look at some of the offerings here at
the wearable technology show that's
coming up after a roundup of this week's
tech news we got to see the first
pictures of the test track for a
futuristic transport system that could
cut the journey time from London to
Edinburgh to 45 minutes Hyperloop is
being worked on in the Nevada desert to
carry commuters in capsules that could
reportedly reach speeds of up to 800
miles per hour nominations for the BAFTA
games Awards were announced but
uncharted 4 leading with eight
nominations post behind is inside with 7
the ceremony is next month
uber drivers look set to start ferrying
non-emergency patients to and from
hospital in parts of London it's after a
deal between an NHS trust and a social
care company and Jaguar Land Rover
unveiled a new car customized for the
Red Cross the project hero vehicle is
fitted with its own drone allowing
crisis team to reach disaster zones when
a car alone can't stick around for our
games review in just a few minutes it's
you versus the world in no sports
superstars before that though let's talk
wearable
I want to start with well the makers
tell me are the world's first conductive
tights coming Jim and model Gareth
you're wearing the tights Jim I should
say for our UK viewers that over here we
would call these leggings not a tight
but tell me what they do well basically
we have conductive panels in these
tights that you wear while sleeping to
promote micro circulation for rapid
recovery after exercise so is Gareth
being quietly electric yeah basically
he's being conducted the leg in
stimulate muscles through the night -
apparently boost healing Sarah would you
realistically wear these to bed
I would out of interest or would out of
interest other performance linked
exhibits here include technology to
monitor brainwaves of upcoming Formula
One drivers while they're on the track
we can actually see you when a driver
gets for example agitated it's not too
sure about the track doesn't really know
what to do
or if there's any other underlying issue
and then we can use that information to
devise a training plan that exactly taps
into how their brain works talking of
training how about this for a workout so
this is really my thighs are really
working pretty hard to do this oh
there's a portable strength training
device under his right foot in case you
were wondering it can tailor exercise
suggestions to your own strength level
push push push as hard as can push push
nice push push push push
16 nice okay very good not technically a
wearable but leo says it's pocketable
you can do this anywhere
remember wearables come in many forms
with many functionalities here's the
glove that translates sign language for
speech disabled people fingers wired
with sensors collect data from movements
that's converted to text then speech
this will allow them to go out freely
and interact without having someone to
help them communicate then there are the
more recognizable types of wearable this
t-shirt lets you draw on it with
glow-in-the-dark ink that soon
disappears bringing the snapchat concept
to clothing why so imagine a night out
with your friends and you can draw
anything you like onto the t-shirt and
it will last for five minutes and then
just completely disappears when you come
to cover this event do you think wow
this is a glimpse of the future or do
you think it's a roomful of fatty
gimmicks I wouldn't necessarily say body
gimmicks but it's definitely
technologies that are very niche and
aren't gonna ever make it into the
mainstream they'll be very useful for a
certain segments for people but it's not
something that you or I will be wearing
but let's not get bogged down with the
future especially when there's still so
much for me to have a go on here
oh and note to self bring actual workout
gear next time we're gonna switch over
from tech you can wear the tech you can
play because it's video games time is
luke near automata is a new action RPG
title from Platinum Games who are
probably best known for their work on
the Bayonetta franchise with that in
mind you can expect fast and phonetic
combat and beautifully realized worlds
what's different this time around and
this often isn't platinum is it is a
massive open world replete with all that
you'd expect in a quality RPG so hub
towns the ability to upgrade weapons
ability to sell things and it is all
gorgeously realised with beautiful
beautiful enemies the one thing that is
a little bit weak that I would watch out
for is the story which goes from naught
to bonkers in about two seconds flat but
if you can handle that there is a
fantastic game here that you
would be a fool to this hour
[Music]
Mario sports superstars is a new 3ds
title from the team at Camelot who made
Mario Golf World Tour which was an
excellent title this time around they've
expanded their ambitions and attacking
five different sports which are football
baseball golf tennis and horse riding
now some of you may be worried that that
means the games will be diluted but
thankfully they are all incredibly
robust and enjoyable in their own rights
what's even better from my perspective
is while there is online multiplayer
there's also local co-op so you can play
with your friends there's 18 different
characters available from throughout the
Mario franchise and best of all for me
with the switch launched in last week
some people have been concerned that
this will mean the 3ds will be neglected
by Nintendo but this is a very strong
mission statement to prove that that is
not the case
super Bomberman our is another Nintendo
switch launch game and the latest entry
in the very long-running Bomberman
franchise gameplay essentially revolves
around running around 2d grid dropping
bombs to try and trap and blow up other
Bomberman
unfortunately this just reeks of
nostalgia for me and there isn't
anything new here if it had been
launched late in the console cycle I
don't really feel it would be a viewed
as anything other than just a niche
title if you're desperate for something
to play on your switch then if by all
means pick it up but when it's sitting
next to Zelda on the Shelf I struggle to
recommend it don't forget you can watch
any of us on demand and all the usual
places and why not follow us on Twitter
perhaps I knew quite I'll be back next
week if you can join us then bye-bye
[Applause]
you